some of the work we do is related to
security to computer security in
particular there is a government agency
called GCHQ in the UK which stands for
government communications headquarters
so they're sort of super Authority in
the UK that looks after all things
through security including computer
security and they've come to us a little
while ago
with a really interesting question
basically they said mmm we're looking at
all of computer systems and is there any
way we can measure how secure they
really are and how do we understand what
our experts are saying data mining is
all about crunching large volumes of
data but then you come to these points
where suddenly there's all sorts of data
there but it's realized in human
expertise and it's not so clear anymore
what exactly you're looking for and here
it's a classic example so you get your
expert to look at a computer system and
this is actually some real data this is
the unclassified version I don't have to
shoot you when you have to go you're
okay this is an example where actually
lots of experts from GCHQ have been
asked to assess the security of a system
the details I can't reveal but there was
a particular system that was set up
there was different ways of attacking
the system and the experts were
basically asked ok tell me this
particular type of attack on a scale of
1 to 10 do you think is easy or
difficult and this is the answers we got
and each dot is a particular expert the
colors relates to what part of GCHQ
they're working in it might be in
slightly different subgroups and it can
see some of the experts they said oh
yeah this is a really easy attack to do
they gave it rank number one myself two
experts actually said oh it's kind of in
the middle some experts say no no is
really difficult this is number ten and
this is typical for when you're asking
experts I mean these are highly
qualified people and the same is true in
medicine and this is kind of where our
work started before this and why GCHQ
came to us we worked a lot of doctors
doctors assess patient's and why do you
have to ask a second in the third
opinion it's because they don't always
give you the same answer today so the
same here you ask you different experts
and they can give you very very
different answers it doesn't become a
data mining problem anymore now because
well what you going to do with this we
could take the average but the average
is probably completely wrong because
what's
really happening here is one of two
things one either this expert who is
sort of a bit of an outlier
he's untrained and he actually just
needs a bit of training or maybe he just
become aware of a zero-day attack
somebody nobody else knows yet and he
really knows his stuff
well it's these people here that might
work on this date today and I probably
ride in a general sense but maybe
they've missed this latest attack so if
you go for the average you probably end
up if to complete the wrong answer
because either is trivial or there's
something that just happened recently
and we need to find out you can't just
take the average when we will work if
GCHQ that's kind of what it looks like
as a big donut actually so they're
basically saying look lots of government
agencies are coming fast and they say we
want we want our system to be assessed
by your experts how secure is he truly
spent more on security and well okay so
how many experts should be asked is
there any does it matter but if you ask
internal or external experts does it
matter whether we ask experts of
different teams and what do we do when
you get five opinions do we take the
average so through our studies and
through our collection of data we were
able to come up with a number of
findings which were quite interesting
one of the things that we looked at for
example was whether experts which are
internal to the organization and experts
which are external to the organizations
give different answers maybe they have
different training maybe they have
different use of experience and one of
the things we found wall start actually
the internal and the external experts as
a whole they give more or less the same
answers so that was good because there
was some concern on GCHQ is part that
they need to be very careful there who
they select but turns out now and it's a
mixture is good another thing that we
looked at most different groups of
experts do they give different answers
it turns out that some groups they're
obviously very narrowly technically
focused and they will always give you
more or less the same answer whereas
other groups that seem to be broader and
they give you a wider variety of answers
so while it's may be good idea to ask
five experts it's not a good idea to ask
five experts from some group because it
doesn't matter it is a wasting your time
in getting five times the same answer so
you might want to ask out the five
people from these other groups or five
people from different groups networks
yeah so somebody might some of these
groups that might be really really
focused on firewalls so they know
everything about firewalls so when the
are
about firewall talk I'm gonna say the
same thing but his other groups
well they've studied more broader things
all that come it can't just be a little
bit the dynamics of the group
maybe there's a very strong leader in
some groups so everybody will give you
the opinion of the leader base in other
groups is a bit more free thinking what
we really after is computer security and
understanding how secure is the system
ideally what we want is a measure of
security and to obtain such a measure
this is a computer to computer science
issue we get data we get data by asking
experts there's also data by not asking
suppose we have data by the system I
mean look for example this is kind of
what a system looks like here's an
Edward this is how many hops there are
there's a firewall here there's an
encryption machine there there's a
content checker here you've got all this
information as well so you've got all
this information and you've got the
expert opinions now how do you put it
all together to give you a number or
something that tells you okay actually
this is how secure we are or we should
spend more money on this or maybe we
don't need to is it possible to do that
I have a bicycle lock and it's rated you
know as to how secure it is I'm guessing
that space 1/2 thick it is how
heavy-duty the metal is but things
change
problem is with this system might be
this secure today and then tomorrow
something happens on the patch a new
patch comes out or an update comes out
and fingers change so what you're
actually gonna get is something more
than a mic here so you have to ask a
question again and again but at least at
this moment in time when you ask your
five experts you're going to get a
consistent answer or at least you know
how to get a consistent answer out of
their opinions one of the things that we
found about this which is very
interesting and here's a publication
where you can read much more about this
because these computer systems are very
communicative things many hops many
stages many different ways of attacking
them this is where humans we have a
problem we can't have all the
information in our head all the time
so one of the things that we're
interested in is how do experts actually
form their opinion of this and it turns
out that what experts really do is they
look at the whole system and they
identify which one of the many steps is
the most difficult step they call it the
most difficult hop and once they've
identified the most difficult hop they
then think very hard ok how difficult is
this most difficult hop for example the
encryption machine might be the most
difficult
breaking the encryption how difficult is
that and they give that the rating
between one and ten and their final
rating for the whole overall system is
95% of the rating decay for this most
difficult table which I shows you how we
as humans you know do our data mining
really simple so that's that's basically
said that you may as well we may as well
use that same technique is that that's
right that's basically one way you can
do it I mean if you if you happen before
95% answer which you might be happy on
most systems then actually it's
efficient to ask your experts which one
is the most difficult part and how
difficult is this part
one thing that this image has that our
last image of the flower didn't have is
sharp changes in intensity so this C has
a sharp step down into the background
and that is not something that JPEG
handles very well at all but statistics
on its own it's not enough and that's
what computer programming is really good
because it's more flexible than
statistics